メールcottonyhong-ウォン電話なしで
ヨガをマッサージしてもいい
ですか？日本に海外から連れてきたクリスとのQ＆Aは
、私の8倍のチャンネル登録者を見てみ
ましょう。  YouTubeの動画YouTubeの動画を作っ
たのは、日本に来たとき
、どこの真ん中の真ん中の真ん中でタホqに行って
いるところを見上げたように、日本についてのYouTubeの動画があまり
なかったからです。 あなたは日本に来る前にビデオを作っています
ええ私はいくつかの
企業のビデオを作っていました私はそれが特に得意ではありませんでし
たそれは
私がしばしば映画製作者になることを夢見ていた楽しみのためにした単なる趣味でし
た ダストビンですが、とても難しいドリルだと気づき
ました。これまでできなかったと思います
が
、それ以来、状況はかなりうまくいき
ました。YouTubeは、実際にはかなり良い種類の
ペデスタルまたはペデスタルのかなり良い
ステッピングです。 石ええ、どうやって踏み石の台座を手に入れるのか
、それは夢へのかなり良い踏み石ですえ
えと、まだ踏み石の上にあり
ます 日本に住んでいる
ことで、これまでの文化を体験している
ダンカンは、実際にここで聞いたことがあります。
最初の
チリコークスケビン
私が最初にクリスに会ったとき、面白い話
はありませんでした。
ついに会ってから3時間くらいだったので、
ローガン
はあまり一般的な名前ではないと言ってくれました。
私の本名ではないので、よく言わないで
ください。 彼女は日本に引っ越しているのを知っています。
実際、
私の好きな監督の
1人はサトシを
捕まえました。  ssあなたはあなたの名前を見ましたか
私はすべての雨をしましたええ私は
誰もがそれを好きなので私はこれを好きに
なりたくないと思いましたええ私は同じになりたくありません
ジブリの好きな映画
がたくさんあるのを見たことがありますか？私は実際に
スタジオを見たことがありません。
週に3、4本の映画そのモンスターを軽くするシングルを見たことがない
私
は、専門家がいないという理由だけで映画に入るのが一番良いことを学びました
ええええ私はすべてのフープを通過することを計画していることに同意
します 音楽パフォーマーとして好奇心旺盛な
学位を取得した後、英語を教えることを願っています。
メジャースラッシュ
教育メジャー
外国人が英語以外の科目を教えることはめったにあり
ません。
あなたがするいくつかのスポーツアルトを減らしました
インクあなたはラリーや特定のスポーツを知っていますか
一般的にそれは
英語ですすべてのオプションは限られています
mm-hm
よく私は
フランスの教育の仕事を見つけるのに本当に苦労したフランス人の友人が
日本
を教えるために英語に来ると言いましたがあなたは教えるために英語に来ると言いました 日本私は
おそらく日本を教えるため
に英語に来ましたええ英語の詐欺
に来ました日本私は先生を終えた後に何かをするという考えで英語を教えるために日本に来ました
あなたの好きな
趣味の部外者ユーザーは何ですか
ビデオを撮影するビデオを撮影するビデオを撮影
するビデオを編集する
プロセス全体が私のすべての時間を
費やしますが、私が今自由な時間を費やしていることの1つは
、
私がぶつかろうとしたように、映画製作について学ぶことだと思います
過去6か月間、ビデオの品質のレベル
を上げました。新しいカメラを入手しました。これは簡単な方法ですが、新しいカメラを入手した
ことを知らなかったという事実はあると思います。
おそらく品質の向上を物語って
います。それは私の自由な時間のせいで、私は
別の血まみれのビデオを作成していません。私は
ビデオをより良くする方法を学んでいます。
あなたがそこにいるような気が
するので、私はどうすれば
私ができる最善の方法を考えていました。どう
すればそれを行うことができますか？新しいカメラを持っていると、
新しい素敵な
新しいクールなカメラを作ることができました ショットは
安定しますか？よりダイナミックなショットを行うことができる
ので
、オブジェクトや物の静止ショットを撮るよりも、カメラを使って
ズームインまたはズームアウトできます。
以前の特定のショットのように多くのことを考えましたか
あなたはその場所に行きませんが、私は
そこで一度実験する傾向があるので
、私たちのビデオの主な違いの1つは
、毎回私のビデオが唯一の違いで
あるということです
。 場所やショットなどを取得する
帽子をかぶるかどうかは、もう1つの大きな決断
です。旅行の場合は、1時間ほど
カメラを使って何かを言う
時間がないので、すぐに何かを撮影することが
できます。
インドゥのスクリプトがどこにあるのかを背景に説明する面白いジョーク
コンテンツ
は私のアパートにいる私だけだった
ことがありますここでスクリプト
を作成し
ます しかし、私たちは旅行しますいいえ、
私は基本的
に私が行うすべてのジェスチャーのように反対であり、すべての
ビデオは常にスクリプト化さ
れ、事前に計画されて
います。
同じ映画で同じ
シーンの日本を3〜4回戻っ
て見て、どちらが良いかを見てみましょ
う。
微妙でコメディーが非常に重要だ
と思います。通常
、eacの各行で10〜20テイクを行います。 私のビデオの1つは、
本当にそうですね。でも、その大部分
は、私が日本語で上手くやっているという事実です。
通常、最初
の少なくとも最初の5つのテイクのように、私
は日本語を正しくしようとしています。
日本人が正しければ、ジェスチャーなど
の自然さについて考え始めることができます。
私のようなビデオのほとんどは、
2分の長さを知らないのですが、最初の
生の映像は常に
1時間以上ですが、つまり ええ、
私はあなたのビデオが実際の生活とはかなり違うコメディービデオを作って
いたと言うことができますが、あなたは日本を教えるために英語に来ると
言います 私たちの
ステレオタイプは日本人
がよく見つめていると思いますすべての日本人
はフレンドリーで礼儀正しいです私は時々
年配の人、特に年配の男性
は非常に失礼で迷惑なことがあります
ドラシズム私
は時々
年配の日本人男性の前で経験
します彼らは彼らが行くこのことをしますが彼らは意見がありませんがそれは
彼らが意見を
述べているというわけではありません
ウェスリアンの文化
ではこういうのが私の意見
です今聞いてほしいドゴンですが日本ではみんな
が意見を控えているようなので少し
飲んだかもしれませんが漏れる可能性があり
ます 母私
はクールなオタクのスコッチコンフィをする方法を見るだろう
夫はこれがすべて良いと思った
あなたのお気に入りのコンビニエンスストアの戦いと私の
お気に入りのコンビニエンスストアがセブンイレブンである理由
たとえば、ファミリーマート
は最高のフライドチキンを持っていますローソンは
私が好きな最高のコーヒーを
持っています彼らが最近実装したチーズトルティーヤのために
それらは
良いヒントやアドバイスをあなたたちに
与えるでしょう 一時的に日本に来て働きたいと思っている人は
最低
1年から5年くらいですええええそれは
一時的にここに来るだけです5年以上
日本に滞在したい人に英語を勧めない
理由は
しばしば 人々
は日本に住むという概念に夢中になっていて、
英語を教える
ことは日本に行くための手段にすぎず
、実際に英語を教えることに興味がないことに気づいて
いません。
スコットカウンティは
、
大学を卒業して何かの学位を取得したく
ないので、5年間で英語
を教える以外のスキルセットを開発することについて語っています。 母国語であり、
基本的にテープレコーダーとして機能します。
仕事のような瞬間を特定します。そうそうそうそうそうそう
、これを行うためのコンサルタントの仕事です。彼は
グーグルやデロイのような家に友達がいます。
彼が好きな人と同じように
、Q＆A全体を通して笑顔に
なります。
スタンレー・
クブリックのフェアのように、あなたにインスピレーションを与え
続けているので、私は非常に不安になると思います。
しかし、
人生は1つの大きなビデオゲームの
ようなものであり、誰かに会うたびにRPGのようなものであり、
新しい冒険と興奮を解き放つクエストのようなものです
。GTAに参加して山をドライブし、
正しいことをする
ことができます。いつも驚きました。 人々がSkyrimやGTAのようにプレイしているのを見る
と、彼らはそうです。
彼らがそれらのゲームで何をしているのか知っています。
現実の世界でビジネスを構築できると思います
。2つの場所で人々と出会うことができます。
何か正しいことを考えて、それを
実現させるという考えを私に与え
て
くれます。youtuberという言葉は嫌いです。 東京に行ってあなたのビデオを作ろうとしたら
今日ここであなたに会うだけでどこかに行って旅行しよう
私は
この日本の著者がよく呼んだこの本を読んだ。この本
はカニエハによってミンカと呼ばれた。
ドゴン族は実際に
はこの本の短い物語の1つであるが、彼女は
統合失調症の人の観点から書い
ている。 彼女が言うように2ページ
、そして今起こったことは実際
に私の想像の中にあり、これが
実際に起こっ
ていることであり、非常に創造的な何かが存在する可能性があること
、または
6ページ後に精通するねじれがその方法であることに私を驚かせたよう
です 彼女はそれをとても説得力のあるものにしたので
、あなたが彼女のようにあなたに立ち寄ったのは
、それ
が起こる
たびに驚きになり
ました。 そして、
eを使って行きたいと思ったのは
、嫌いなメールビデオからのコメントのよう
に見えることです。
あなたが酔っているのは、あなたたちが関係しているかどうかを尋ねる人がいますか
？
私は起きたことがありませんが、私たち
は少し似ていると思いますええ
、特定のサイドアングルプロファイルは
あなたが私よりもはるかにスリムだと思います
私は側にいる
人々が彼らの決心をすることができる側に目を向ける
スパイダーマンまたはスパイダーマンのフラッシュスポット量
あなたは別の言語を学びたいです
か-そしてあなたの答えが
イエスならそれは巨大なイエスで
あり、その言語 スペイン語でこんにちは
-5年間はかっこいいですが
、お城があるので大丈夫
です。私の道徳的な試験では
お城があるのでクリスタルのようだったので、
彼女が笑うのはまったく意味がありませんでした。
私が知っているより多くの日本人が さらに悪いことに、YouTubeの作成に非常に興味がある限り、私の
英語はかなり
英語になり、日本に教えるように
なります。
別の言語を
習得するのは難しいでしょう。スペイン語のような別の言語を学んだら、私は
そうします。 スペインに住んでいる間、それ
は言語を学ぶことの本当の興奮
です。私にとって日本語を学ぶことの半分の楽しみは
、文法を教える文章を学ぶように
それを使用し、それを日常生活で見ることを知って使用すること
は
興味深いものです。
それが今のあなたの人生を要約していると思いますか、
待つか、自分で作ることができますか私
はあなたの最も
嫌いな日本語の単語や
フレーズであるピートのイディオムを考えるにはあまりにも平和が必要です
それはどういう
意味ですか？唾を吐くとは氷がすごいという意味です。
文字通りの翻訳ではありません。実際の
翻訳はまあまあです。
それは普通のことです。
私の神、それ
は私
が1つの写真で何が起こっているかを知っている唯一の日本のYouTubeの人のようです
ロッシキャットキャットバリーはバリーできません
彼女は非常に興奮しています
ロッシ
キャドベリーにメッセージを送ります クリスと同じくらい多くの加入者
あなたの好きな種類のプリンは何
ですか、そしてなぜそうなるのですか？これは
ジェニーです私は好きではないのでフレディ
は好きなおもちゃを持っていますええと彼は彼自身の
自家製ジンジャービールジンジャージンジャーエール
ジンジャージンジャーエールええシンプソンのために
生姜ビールと生姜エールは素晴らしい
発音でしたはいわかりません
おそらく英国では生姜ビールは
非アルコールですおそらく違いはないでしょう
国によって違いはないので、あなたの好きな
プリン生姜エールは何キロですかクリス私は何キロ
ですか？ よく考えてください
私がまっすぐ立っていると私は完全に185センチです
ので、どのくらいの
重さですか？人々が6768キロを作るのを手伝って
ください
シャワーの前または後は、
私がすべての芸術にシャワーを浴びる内容によって異なり
ます。あなたが日本人になっている明確な答えはあり
ません。
白人に
日本について
知ってもらいたいことは何ですか？質問の意味はわかりません
が、それはいいことだと思います。
外国人に
日本について知って
もらいたいことそれは四季のある国です
白人に日本について知ってもらいたいのは
あなたが日本にいるからといって特別ではないということです
それは本当に良い点ですこれ
はあなたのローガンプールビデオの一種です 今
、このトラベスはよくありませんこれは
私が
話したいと思っていたトピックです外国人との観点から
日本の現在の状況は誤解されていると思います
日本人を話すことができる日本の外国人
は、20年
または30年前のよう
なものだと思います。日本語を本当に上手に話すことができれば、それはこの大規模な取引のようであり、実際には100万人に1人のようです。
日本には何千、何千、何千もの外国人
が日本語を話しますが、私と同じように
彼らはそれについてのユーチューブビデオを作っ
ていない
だけです。
ドゴンからクリスまでこの質問をしたいの
ですが、終わったら私に聞いてください。
これは私の無意識の言い方
です。
映画や映画に興味があるので、
好きな映画は何ですか。 私
が学生だった頃、監督はマーティン・スコセッシでした。マーティン・
スコセッシの制作方法から誰かの作品を特定できるという理論を変えることができました
が、
グッドフェローズとラギンを勉強しました。  g
ブルああそうそう、それは絶対に
信じられないほど
の私のスコットでした。
彼が好きなトリックは、ボクシングリングの形を変えて、
より激しく感じさせ
、ボクシングリングに煙を入れ
てそれを高め、気分を良くするように、詰め込まれた人々が喫煙しているように感じさせました。
地獄にそれを言っていたええ、あなたが
レイジングブルを見ればそれは映画のマスタークラス
ですロジャーディーキンスの映画は
私がブレード
ランナー2049ザカリアノーカントリーフォーオールド
メンスカイフォールスカイフォールかどうかを知っているようです私はそれを考えるのが本当に好きでし
た 特に良いボンド
映画でした。映画撮影
は素晴らしかったので、映画撮影者
はゲットーを上げることができ
ます。リドリー・スコットはリドリー・スコットが好きだと思いますか。
いくつかの素晴らしい映画ええブレード
右最初のブレードは
10本の映画のように私のトップの1つ
を丸めます
元のエイリアンをがらくた元のエイリアン
彼がはるかに他の監督である私のお気に入りの映画
コーエン兄弟ええええ
私はクエンティン・タランティーノが好きなコーエン兄弟が大好きです
彼との最近のちょっとしたセッションは、
デヴィッド・フィンチャーとアーロン・ソーキンです。
彼の執筆は
次のレベルのようですが、ええ、これは特に良かったショーです
。 大丈夫、私は実際
にそれらの映画を見たことがありません。
グランドブダペストホテルのようなブダペストホテルは私のお気に入りの映画の1つです。
映画の形で劇場のパフォーマンスを見るようなものです。キャメロンはどうですか？ 彼の
名前を今すぐBure彼の名前を撃ちます彼は彼
がした血があります彼はマグノリアをしました彼は
パンチバーをしました 確かに間違い
なくこれがあなたの新しいビデオについて私が好きな
ことの1つだと思うことの1つは、メディアに関係なく一般的にアートで伝えるのが非常に難しいと思うことの1つ
は、漠然としていますが
激しい感情です。
たとえば、怒りと悲しみの中間のようなものだった
ので、少し曖昧ですが、強烈な
権利なので、この種の反射は
、私が再びとても大げさなように聞こえますが、
人間の本性は、
それを非常によく捉えているように非常に大きく反映されていると思います 犯罪
による忘却のような私のお気に入りの曲のように
、それが
悲しいのか、それともインスピレーションのようなものなのかわからないようなものです。
それが本当に良いものだと思うので
、エンディングが好きだったの
です。 血があまりにも多いので
、ネタバレのない血があることの終わりを説明したくないようなものです。
私の意見では、天才レベルで実行される曖昧さ自体は難しい
です。それは
あなたが見ているあなたの宿題である血があるという良い言い方です。
ドゴン族は
哲学的でジンジャーエール
だらけの会話でしたええそれは
美しいです
ええそれはとても素敵ですええそれはここで初めて久州にクリスがいるのはとても良かったです
あなたがこれまでにそれを愛したなら、ええ、
人々はあなたがどこに住んでいるのか知っていますか私はタマリンドと言うことができます
ええ私はベッドに住んでいるので香り
と道と後ろの年齢は
美しい
です バスルーム
はカリフォルニアか何かにいるように感じました
うーん、ヤシの木と
山と海ああ、それは素晴らしい
場所ですええと、タキシはあなたの家族を
連れてきてあなたの友達を連れてきてあなたの猫を連れてきますええ
しかし今私は北に戻らなければなら
ないと思います ここから北に千キロ離れたところ
に送るのは
、シャツも差し込む必要があります。シャツ
もありますが、お酒のように子供たちを[ __ ]するのはうんざりです
が、言葉遊び
です。